good humans welcome to another episode
of odd man out that's right for all you
k-pop fans out there and the BTS army
this one is for you it's super grateful
to our sponsors simple habit for
bringing this episode to you guys it's
an amazing meditation app Eden meditates
all the time I do I'm a busy man
I get frenzied all the time but when I
meditate in the morning it just calms me
down and simple habit is all about
mental well-being and being grounded so
it's a really nice thing to work with
them now enjoy the episode I will
literally have a tattoo of my bias on my
ankle
me Kim Matt b4v work and maybe for
something else okay you know I'll take
it I'll take it we brought together
seven BTS fans I'm a BTS they Iowa BTS
fans I am a BTS man I am a BTS fan I'm a
BTS man i'ma BTS man I am a BTS fan one
is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
[Music]
if the lier survives he or she wins the
entire prize
[Music]
all right so I guess we should just go
around and talk about how we got into
BTS the first person to start talking I
was going to suspect him immediately
right when the buzzer started she was
like okay guys I actually started just
because I wanted to see what like the
hype of kpop was and soon after I bought
tickets to the concert
it started in February and I've been
whipped ever since so I got into loving
BTS in January and like I was like
digging their fashion ever since I'm
like so obsessed
yeah they dress great but I was like I
don't think that's the reason you become
a fan I don't know I just thought it was
weird that he said and he's the
supporter because of their fashion so
one of my best friends her dad actually
was one of the concert organizers for
the wing story and so she was like hey I
have like extra tickets and then after
that I was like oh my gosh like I have
to get into them and it was just like so
do you guys like all consider yourselves
like fan or army cuz you know there's
like a difference you know what I mean I
would say I'm army I'd say I'm
borderline I'm army army because I'm a
newer fan I would say fan like actually
I'm not even like knowing of this big
difference until now so what are your
friends your age think about like you
being army I mean Wolf's being army
don't leak air so you like openly tell
them that yeah yeah well tay is a little
you know older than us like everybody
else was in the box and that kind of
threw me off at first i think it's cool
but even i was like kind of a grown-ass
man yeah i'm saying all right we got a
minute left the trophy everyone oh i'm
double bias hey and javi so my ultimate
bias is jungkook and then i was bias
tricked by jimin and judy is coming for
me
looking at the vice every single one and
then decide like who's your biases so
you don't have a buddy i mean not really
I would maybe nom d'un only because he's
a martyr but well I'll be Kobe on Pepsi
but we got three seconds so logic Malala
ha all right Alan definitely wasn't
giving us as much as we wanted Trinity
she was like emanating some type of
energy you next to me guys everybody had
a little too much info easy to slip by
as just a casual army so my one of my
plans were eliminate the baby armies
first I was able to get some indication
with the last two seconds of the game
okay
so if I go Tony Montana I'm not gonna
lie I don't know that I know what you
mean exactly that's where my delineation
of all right now my fear is it might be
a baby army or again fully admitted to
my fear like joining us in February
you got an alleged Molalla Tony Montana
these are just inside jokes every army
knows I had no idea I'm sorry from
uncultured I'll fix that after this I
know most of the YouTube videos which is
why I'm actually confused as to why I
don't know that but I mean if I have to
whip it out I will I literally have a
tattoo of my bias on my ankle we show us
your jokes and my best friend has one of
J in the same place for demon Kim that
b4v okay I'm a bee for something else I
don't know that could be like a janky
Nike swish that could be a whole lot of
things I don't know so you said you were
you got into them since February of this
year yes what albums have you listened
to I mean pretty much all of them I'd
say my favorite one is probably speak
yourself because that's like what got me
into them there's they don't have an
album that's named speak yourself it's
love yourself so you love this new album
this past album what b-side dude
from the album oh my god b-side on it
all right like that's not oh okay um
home homes my favorite who's gonna be
honest I wasn't a huge fan of the last
time I wasn't I was like what am I
talking about everyone is all you and
started asking me and I was all like I
literally forgot everything like you
don't we want to get anybody who has any
type of suspect feeling out because I
trust my gut I just seriously bought
that there's no way this dude y'all made
me expose my tattoo just to call me fake
that's that okay so you said you were
borderline yeah I'm borderline why cuz I
just started in like 2017 and I guess
cuz my like obsessive k-pop phase is
behind me because I started getting its
a kpop in late 2010 I feel like when you
are in army you were proud to represent
so you don't just say mmm I'm if he
about it okay I was knee-deep in the
YouTube world and I was so obsessed with
BTS so I decided to apply it to the
airport because I knew that they fly
through the air to work yeah I actually
got a job at LAX just to see BTS I know
tragic how did you guys feel about the
be free commentary Oh years ago from how
many call them girls and that whole
thing with the rap community and at I
mean let's be honest for the most part
even the Korean hip-hop community or
especially the idol community some of
the worst cultural appropriators you'll
ever mean but at the same time you have
to understand it's a country of like
it's almost it's a homogeneous country
the question I asked it was like the
deflected so I was like oh yeah we don't
have to keep this going a bit the
culture appropriation is just one thing
but it's more so Holloway Club
opportunity you made them feel like
other that's why yeah babe because again
it there
efficiently just taking what they think
hip-hop is I feel like when they first
started out there was just this like
adamant like I want to be this alpha
male I want to be this up like it wasn't
that easy you know he that was back when
he had the perm but we're not gonna
speak about that he doesn't want to
think about this just like the glow-up
was just it's just been immaculate with
their yeah she was so vocal in the like
the first two rounds but then in third
round when we were getting really deep
she was crickets I was late hey seemed
to know a little bit too much too many
like official things textbook kind of
things yeah yeah could I have one doubt
I guess I started realizing you could
still be a kpop fan but not be a BTS fan
okay what's your doubt my doubt because
you had no idea when I said watching
Malala you did this blinks I'm not gonna
lie I feel like she could be like a
multi that's not that doesn't ulti BTS
you're saying a lot of textbook things
text especially when we started getting
into the be free thing you Amelie
started about cultural appropriation
like okay that's kind of not on topic
because that's something that was
evident and all of kpop like that's
another conversation we could talk about
that later favorite V live episode hmm
trying to think back to when he did the
album review okay what's your favorite
brand BTS episode right if you have if I
have one I'm not gonna I don't think
I've seen every army bomb but my
favorite run BTS probably when they were
in the sauna why was that five six
episodes ago
a lot of our fandom knows and loves
these videos we talk about them all the
time and he was like oh I was like okay
there's so many just choose one like one
was when they went to Six Flags in Texas
and Hobie was on one [ __ ] roller
coaster I don't remember the other one
was when they got scared and they were
supposed to go to the zoo but then they
ended up getting scared for zombies now
do we feel confident this game is so
hard you don't know who the mole is
it could be anyone and the only person
you could be hundred percent sure of is
yourself whether you're the mole or army
that's all you can be we won I'm so
happy
like there's no other way we know who's
not army like we can sense it we can
feel it in our bones
[Music]
I am NOT a BTS fan I'm an EXO fan the
one thing that I wasn't surprised about
was that she is an excellent father and
um is definitely pretty vicious towards
each other and I think especially after
today I think it's just silly everyone
was super nice really we're no different
we just like different groups and it's
dumb to fight over something as trivial
as that BTS fans come in all different
shapes and sizes and ages and genders
and races it's just a beautiful fandom
Trinity I got your back girl if anyone
wants to fight you gotta talk to me
first okay let's just keep supporting
the boys I believe their message is
worth getting out to the world one day
everyone could be army it it'd be a
better world satting hey first time and
odd-man-out history
you did it bj honey do not hate on them
all try not to don't hate meditate oh
yeah because this episode is actually
brought to you by simple habit they have
easy-to-use on-the-go features you can
do a 5 minute meditation and 10 minute
meditation they also have like specific
courses for you know specific symptoms
like stress anxiety public speaking
breakups
whatever you need you'll find a simple
abbas and make sure you check them out
it's simple heaven calm / odd man out
it's free check it out
as always make sure you like subscribe
and we will see you next time
[Music]